so grammarians we have this class of
words called adjectives and what they do
is they change stuff adjectives
change stuff
adjectives change stuff
they're part of this larger category of
words that we call modifiers
because that's that's what they do they
they modify they change things
so let's say i were to draw you a bear a
kind of human looking standing on two
legs kind of bare sure
i could refer to this bear and i could
say
the bear
but i can also refer to this bear with a
description like
the friendly bear
but if that bear were blue for instance
i could describe the bear as
the blue bear
and in the blue bear the word blue
modifies
bear
blue is an adjective that describes bear
so adjectives change stuff
and they describe stuff
and if that bear were a different color
it would be you know the red bear
and now that bear is red actually more
of a salmon color frankly
let's put this into action with some
sentences
stephen is connie's best friend
now what is the word that describes or
changes another word in this sentence
if you guessed best you are correct best
modifies friend so steven is connie's
best friend what is stephen a friend
what kind of friend is he the best
friend
the enormous pie is not for sale
now what's the what's the adjective in
that sentence
if you guessed enormous you would be
correct enormous which means very big is
modifying or changing the word pie
now i thought a little bit of word
origins might be kind of useful here if
we go back to the latin now you don't
obviously don't need to speak latin in
order to make sense of english but i
thought it would be cool to look at what
adjective literally means
so the word part add
comes from the latin meaning to or
toward or on
and the objective part comes from
a latin word yakere it means to throw
so an adjective is something that's kind
of thrown on or thrown on top of
something because you don't necessarily
need adjectives in order for a sentence
to
make sense the way that you need to have
a verb or the way that you need to have
a noun
adjectives are a little bit extra
they're thrown on top
you know um the these sentences would
work on their own without the adjectives
in them stephen is connie's friend the
pie is not for sale you know they would
work
but
what's nice about adjectives and
modifiers of all kinds is that they add
something extra they add more detail
they change and describe stuff
that's what adjectives do
you can learn anything david out